[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to ultimate
moves it's the 2017 edition where two
teams of super grandmasters plus four
amateurs will go at it with their best
chess moves and also their best
trash-talking it should be a whole lot
of fun we're gonna take it now to the
studio with Gen Y as and Christian
hello I'm Jennifer Shehadeh and I'm here
with Grandmaster Yasser Sarah Juan and
after three weeks of the summer chess we
are ready to have some fun here at
ultimate moves absolutely it's party
time as team wrecks take some teen Randy
in a very unique format where trash
talking is not only allowed it's
encouraged let's take a look at our team
than our formats well let's start with
the format we are going to be at
featuring the top players in the world
and this fast time control we conducive
that in people with graphing in blitz
this is going to be game 5 with a 5
second increment and that increment is
imports of you have been using the
delays but in this case after 5:00 news
the team rotate players so you need a
little time just to get it to the
chariot exactly exactly and six games of
game 5 and they'll be starting every 20
minutes I'll start at 3 3:20 will be the
second round and so forth let's take a
look at the teams but first who is Rex
Sinquefield well for those of you who
are just joining he is of course the
president and the founder of the st.
Louis chess club the best chess club in
the United States which is made st.
Louis the capital of chess in America
absolutely and Rex and Jeanne have done
great work and Randi of course is his
son on the owner spectrum studios who
brings you this great production that's
right so it's so fun to have both of
them if you saw in the shot with Maurice
there is a young blonde boy in the
background peering over that's Logan
Singh field who will also be
participating in the ultimate moves
class right grandson of Rex but now
let's take a look at the team's max team
Rex
we've got Rex Sinquefield and this man
knows how to pick them he's got a Levon
Aronian the same he was rapping Hamlet's
champion as well as Hikaru Nakamura
which led him as well as Sergei car yeah
can we saw
gonna tear nine out of ten and glitz
yatin upon watching a linear Dominguez
crossover with legends and finally the
wild card John or Shaw and John we are
happy to have you with us he is a
retired NFL lineman as well as an MIT
PhD candidate and he's also want to have
a chat by our not a bad wildcard choice
it off and meanwhile on team Randi we
also have a formidable squad including
Fabiano Cara wanna say blue is a local
hair garry kasparov
that's a game we are really excited to
see all week Michigan on five time world
champ as well as David Navarre Ellie
Emily both impressed us with our glitter
blitz in this mess and Rachel Leigh the
wild card 14 Randy Rachel is extremely
impressive to only 7 years old you might
recognize her because she's the sister
of Grandmaster wufeng me who played in
the Masters of Millennials and she's
also almost 1800 now and her us chess
rating and arising every day Wow talk
about the cuteness factor team Rex has
the physical intimidation
speaking of acute factors here he is
logan-san field I'm ready to make the
first move I believe for his daddy Randy
and Christiane who's your pick in these
games
well first of all I'm just very excited
this is my first ultimate moves
experience I haven't even watched a
single ultimate moves but right now I'm
a part of it I'm I'm very very excited I
see a little bit this balance between
the two teams I have a feeling team Rex
is going to dominate
quite heavily because they have a john
herschel who is a Navitus player and
actually a very good chess player we
were solving some studies a few nights
back and they have the best trash talk
trash talkers in the business they have
Levon Aronian
they have Nakamura and John reversal
will be the bodyguard so I think I think
Levon Aronian will be able to expose his
trash shot and not be afraid of other
people just like punching him let's go
to Maurice and we are with the man
himself Rex Sinquefield Rex you've done
this now three times what can we
the fourth edition that's going to be
better than the last if I may quote the
great Maurice Ashley there's gonna be
blood on the floor man doesn't get even
more contentious every year playing
against your son I know that you got to
trash-talk the entire year or whoever
wins it's it's hard to do it some of the
team some of the guys from the other
team have actually shown up you know I'm
saying it should be a ton of fun as Rex
and Randy have this running food we'll
see what happens in just a few minutes I
like that the intimidation factor
already sets in John Herschel presence
that the board has kept some of Randy's
team baby
terrible well I think Rachel's pretty
intimidating as well but Rex Sinquefield
is also my student and so got to be
ready for him in this contest um
although it's always it's always time to
see that it's close you know and we've
got a maureesa back in the board room we
have Randy sing feel the son of Rexy
feel Randy every year it's the same
thing it's Rex talking trash and you
wanted to bring it to him what do you
feel about this year's contest I feel
pretty good I beat him on an online game
recently and that's the first time I are
I'm sorry that's the eighth time I've
beaten him like in my entire life so
he's kind of he's kind of hurt and I'm
feeling pretty good we'll see what
happens I see the young loken you're
bringing him up for the future trash
talkers does he have some skills too
yeah Logan won second place in the city
tournaments so you know he's an
up-and-coming chess player and hopefully
our Sinquefield legacy he's here to make
the honorary first move today
awesome well good luck with your chances
today Randy Sinquefield and Rex it's so
much fun tell me you're trash-talking is
it gonna get worse this year you know my
dad does all the trash-talking I try to
keep it civil and focus on the the moves
try to make ultimate moves and let him
make the ultimate blunders all right Joe
cool you got here Randy sing feel guys
back to you the studio Thank You Maurice
Jennifer I think you're in a conflict of
interest here wait a minute if he's your
student you're rooting for him
I'm gonna have to be really pro Randy in
this case all right well you know I'm
just reading for some fun and some
games as we see the star studied a
boardroom there I thought captive our
Bahamians bright purple here I saw dr.
genies in fields who of course along
with racks founded this gem here in the
Central West in the st. Louis chess club
Ramirez and Michael quarter coffee also
I can spot them out I saw in there we
have it I'm Rachel night yeah estimate
the cuteness factory that's really big
and these ultimate unions and Yan Nepal
Miyagi it looks like LaVon and John are
getting comfortable like the important
thing here for the Grandmaster to make
sure that the ammeter is feel
comfortable they don't feel too thrust
out that they're gonna be hated if they
make a bad move
oh absolutely and there you see two
great legends which she and Gary as
people getting ready and Rachael
let's go to Maurice it looks like and
we've got young Rachel Lee this the
sister of Grandmaster Roofing Lee rachel
is a 1700 player Rachel are you excited
about this what are you a demon make out
1800 she's already contentious here
Rachel what do you feel about being able
to play with all these great players I
think we'll win of course because I can
only open I can open position they get
they get like wow Rachel tell us you're
playing with with team Randy do you
think Rex stands a chance I hear you
beat Rex all the time
you don't think they have a chance no
none at all confident young lady here
she's bringing in guys Thank You Maurice
oh boy I can't it's party time here in
st. Louis look we've had three weeks of
combative elite chess and now it's time
just to let it all flow and get all of
those stresses and tensions out of these
tournaments so we're gonna just have a
good time today
caller 17 Missy looks like Logan's gonna
be playing the first move for Randy Rex
Sinquefield shaking hand that I think
one of his foes there will identify that
man quite soon I see when you're dominga
in the background I thought it was
karaoke and again just to recall a
remind everybody what's gonna happen is
Randy and Rex are each gonna make the
first five moves and then they'll rotate
in one of the two they're teammates and
they'll be grandmasters facing off
against each other for five moves at a
time until we come to the wild cards and
then the whole cycle will repeat the
game is still in progress that's right
so the key thing is these first time
user or I mean Randy and Rex play a lot
and I think these first five moves are
gonna be totally solid unless somebody
pull some kind of crazy opening surprise
jeez damn it after that it's gonna get
really wet and wild around move 30
because that's when the editors are
gonna sub in and let's go up to Maurice
Ashley with John Herschel and we are
with former NFL lineman John Herschel
who will be playing on Rex's team team
Rex now we had little Rachel Lee on the
other side Rach Rachel was in
trash-talking she said you guys don't
stand a chance you'll be going up
against Rachel what are your feelings
about that I feel like when you're
playing a seven-year-old it's a
lose-lose how so well she can trash talk
me I'm not sure you know you trash talk
a seven-year-old there's there some
problems there try to say you're gonna
just lose this competition no I'm saying
I'm gonna win but you know we're winning
with class
all right well this guy he's the he's
the muscle if anything bad happens yeah
he's gonna take somebody down a big man
right here but he's got to bring the big
moves well we are about to start this
competition everyone's all set rex is in
place Randy's in place we've got the
team of GM's looking very dapper
most of them looking like they got their
suits on so I'm very relaxed this is the
event that has culminated after a great
summer of chess here in st. Louis so
we're about to start let's get
everything started with our arbiter
Chris bird okay folks can I have
everyone's attention please just really
quickly
thank you first thing I'd like to say is
Rex you're a little late for the drawing
of lots here so we actually drew colors
and Randy got white in the first game
don't worry we're playing six games so
you'll get three whites as well so it's
okay we have over here we have team Rex
everybody to the right of LaVon and over
here we have team Randy everybody to the
left how this is gonna work it's very
simple five moves after five moves I'll
tell you to switch and then my two
assistant arbiters who are now team
managers will bring up the next person
let them know who it is who's next and
they'll come on and switch out so
there's a specific order for each round
and the team managers will be in charge
of that a couple of quick rules
we're playing regular chess rules feed
air rules so illegal move those lose
[Music]
an illegal an illegal palm promotion
will loose touch move if you touch it
and it can legally move yes you have to
move it yes okay okay one other quick
rule that we have trash-talking is
allowed but you cannot give any hints
and talk about specific moves okay so
you can trash talk all you like but no
no talking about specific moves you can
obviously stand up and watch the game
you can see the game on the screen and I
think with that being said I think we're
gonna have Logan make how a ceremonial
first move I'll pack it back pass it
back to Maurice thank you very much
thank you very much Chris
all right Logan is gonna make the
ceremonial first move the trash-talking
is not only allowed it's required as a
matter of fact Tony rich said he's gonna
find anyone who doesn't trash talk so
the players better bring it now well the
move about to begin and Chris Logan it's
on you a good player learning from his
dad as the generation continues and
there it is the first football to my
movie I begun yeah oh you you trained
Rex well with his accelerated dragon
Jennifer he's going from rocks he is
Randy oh he did nine more passive rude
and I think that the Black team Rex is
gonna be happy when a dome switches back
to them yes and here we have Fabiano
Carolina on Team Randy and Levon Aronian
our sample was rapid in blitz champion
subbing in and it's gonna be until move
31 through 35 until we get the ammeter
is back in so a lot of grandmaster moves
fasten your seat belts this is where the
games gonna get hairy
exactly
and the players are playing very very
quickly a dragon because it's game 5
with 5 second increments so white will
have to focus on the kingside I would
say 9 H 2 or maybe night II 1 92 93 and
then f4 and black is just going to try
to expand on the queenside yeah it's
very awkward for white with the knight
on f3
it's definitely blocking the f-pawn from
advancing and the point is not only 5
that's ok we're switching some players
like a big smile by Gary and a big
square any big square and he carves
which this is this is team keep
Wrexham's bagging karo Nakamura kick her
over is Gary that's a beautiful match
talk about pulling out your big guns
early and Optima racism thoughts and
we're with Fabiana Caruana was made the
first 5 booze for the GM's Fabi how do
you feel about your opening so far could
be better but it's it looks good enough
Gary's seems pretty confident Levon
seemed very confident as a matter of
fact you know he won just just won the
rapid and blitz he looks like he's on
top of the world right now how do you
feel about that I can tell from his
moves they roll extremely strong all
right we'll take it back down to you
guys in the studio
thank you very much his team and Fabiano
of course is on Randy's game but i think
john herschel said it best you don't win
by trash-talking a 7 year old I think we
need a coffee but what about the
position you think White's
game has improved a little bit looks
like Gary's got a little path plan here
well he's just played to move a 283 that
we've seen this big trade of the night
the bishop for the night on the d4 score
so double pawns in the center ok b5 very
good night c6 is on the board we also
have a b5 on the board it's smart for he
carved a place so quickly I think Rex
did a good job picking his GM's because
then that way when the amateurs come in
they're gonna have
more time now the c5 opens up and who
has the advantage that's the question
Maurice with LaVon himself we are with
the winner of the st. Louis and wrap it
in blitz himself a man about to get
married and a little over a month LaVon
how do you feel about the position right
now for your team well I think and you
know I was trying to not to play the
best moves but I just can't help it
comes automatically you think your team
is going to carry it to the finish line
well I did my part so it all is now in
their hands and they're they're
experienced players and I put my trust
in them all right heavy trust guys back
to you Thank You Maurice like that moves
just flow for Levon as he is one of
course there were st. Louis rafter the
Blitz and there's Michigan on departing
look at that smile
exactly he's looking very presentable
today very sharp yeah he's ready to make
some ultimate moves first retreat wait
who do we have in the city yeah and
let's like it well play games by both
sides so far he as with both of them
claiming their their space but still
kind of like black with that nice little
V for rocking the world
exactly I'm afraid young will be
actually detrimental to his team I
played with him back house last night
and I was the same team and he was
actually trash-talking me partner and
and I've seen him talking to LaVon
telling him how he should have done
things a certain way so I'm not sure
that might be detrimental to little to
the themes you juicy-looking III Square
for the night the night gets that there
that'll be worth a look
Oh that'll be a powerful powerful piece
what is it my doing on g5 you see that
there's a big question well whoa okay
have some trades on the C file now looks
like a massive massive trades on the C
file indeed um yeah I'm trying to keep
pieces in the word by capturing with the
bishop instead of the rook yeah and he's
done that we with Gary Kasparov Gary you
major comeback you were in control of
your own destiny now you're not in
control you only get to make five moves
what do you feel about the position
right now sharp so we didn't have a good
opening yes very hard time it's
considering the last position of the
first five moves we're probably locate
but we don't definitely now it's sharp
very shortly and definitely game will be
decided by you gotta put it you put your
hands in the seven-year-old girl how you
feel about that right now she's pretty
strong player all right guys Liam Lee at
the board with the white side against a
linear Dominguez and Gary expressing a
dissatisfaction about the opening but he
thinks that his team has fought back
into their way into the game I have a
question the knight was on g5 per se
wooden Queen takes c8 have worked well
like the night on g5 yeah they were
setting up for that but I think that it
got booted back by h7h so Queen to a 7
attacking a three pawn wasn't the Queen
only a six physics okay six
so Queen so that white has control them
to the C file but what to do with it
does Chloe see something yes they say
three greedy to take on a three it seems
like we can we can go for it's nice that
we have that that h7 square for the king
we never worry about like some kind of
Queen see a cactus so Queen takes a
three-night e5 Knight e5 is on White's
agenda as Liam was looking to press on
the g6 pawn and that gives very good
practical chances especially when the
amateurs something you didn't take the
pawn he didn't take the pawn that's
he takes a three was played no no
because of a threat to the d3 pawn we
got to protect that guy will put the
knight in the center of the board with
the move Knight e5 and everybody is
enthralled but this has come to play
from the ammeter point of view so I kind
of I'm studying like white even though
the position might be okay for black but
in a couple of moves John Herschel and
Rachel Lee are subbing in Rachel with
white this favors even here we go there
yeah ninety-five King h7 very quickly
played by Dominguez he's protecting the
pawn on g6 but when they turn it over to
the wild cards what's gonna happen
Christian well I take John Herschel
everyday because again I trained him I
trained him like a couple of nights ago
we did puzzles very difficult puzzles
and he was finding them he was solving
this difficult my faith is with team Rex
and John Herschel beat the
seven-year-old it's hard to get more
pieces into the attack isn't it yeah
that's well I'm looking at a really
sharp line that begins g4 for yes 93 or
maybe Knight h4 not sure but then you
got to go Queen e7 right because you're
absolutely right Jen you got to get that
rook on c1 into the game with rook c7
and he has entered the fray I have to
admit she's intimidating URI
I'm telling you the cuteness factor game
face because even beyond on to take a
formidable team a number two wears on
her shoulders daddy
now one thing I would be afraid is the
pressure John is feeling right now but I
have a feeling that he is used to that
because of his NFL
former career oh I think he knows how to
handle the pressure but of course he's
not used to facing when he was facing a
seven-year old size and brain power
gage tell you I thought I thought it was
absolutely vital that that moved g3 g4
be played for Team Randy and offering a
trade of Queens even though it's a
couple of ponds behind in the position
not a good idea
yeah where the Queen wasn't really doing
much on that side yeah that was why I
thought g4 and Queenie 7 was such a
critical maneuver maybe this was best
play by Rachel trying to get the beat
you mean trying to get the B Vipond be
fighting son right yeah and up to
Maurice we've got a five-time world
champion Vishwanath on Anand vichy oh
there in the hands of some amateurs now
two players playing and it's gonna be
Randy and Rex gotta be difficult well
first there's John and Rachel so it's
scary because I have no idea what's
happening on every move you know this
feeling of free fall that's kind of
where I am now so few months ago I liked
it I thought we could get a good attack
with g4 and Queenie 7 but now so it's
not it's not the amateurs fault you're
saying I think we should have given them
something clearer Queens Queens came off
the board and Rachel has just played
rook a six hosting a party
look see six posting up attacking the
bishop on a six and John
good move my John I think they eat six
months he's very important very
important but now we're see why she's
offering a tacit drop
Wow yes is John gonna capture it take
hey good night only five then jump with
a nightly three and prepare your roof
and showing I would have to yeah that
would be a big I'm gonna play it he's
intimidated come on John yeah he doesn't
want to mess it up
you should be seven he's gonna show me
something Bishop back to a six and Rex
and Randi are back in the thick of
things
Randi is seen Rachael's move previously
so he's coming in because that runs into
seven okay see looking at Randy's
looking at rats now then Rex completely
move 1993 she come on the board right
now well I'm thinking Bishop a six guys
Bishop thank you if you want to take my
pawn on b4 I'll take the pawn on b3 that
looks even backed activating the bishop
so big moments here in Game one of this
six-game match up but you know what
Randy seems more clock aware than rats
and directed letting his time tick down
I think he's got three more moves to me
and he has played that I did maybe three
a time move threatening to come down for
the f2 square what you were mentioning
Christian so good so far yeah
we've got to find the MU Kim Jiwon to
stop that rook from penetrating that
could be devastating
oh no he's taken and and then I just
move my butt
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah just that last moment with King
g'wan would have kept the game
competitive and Maurice with the star of
the show over the happy winner Rex
Sinquefield Rex you were responsible for
winning that game you play those
devastating moves 93 rook f2 that won
the game I got lucky you know that
position was sitting there for a long
time for at least 10 or 12 moves I'm
kept wondering why didn't somebody drop
the knight in among their pieces and so
I did yeah I figured well they thought
it was a bad idea so I'll try it it
didn't work
David Navarro said it's not nice to beat
your children what do you feel about
that you know on that I am unambiguously
ambiguous all right victory has been
achieved by Rex's team they're up want
to know Game two will start in a few
minutes I love that you very well put
racks um I saw that Gary at one of Garry
Kasparov's favorite quotes is why not
you so nobody's playing 93 why not me
there we go and let's take a look at the
standings well we won the result that's
right these fabulous photos here by
spectrum Studios we've got one point
fourteen racks and it's euro for Team
Randy but I think it's gonna be a really
tight match guys I don't think so I
don't I think this is going to be a swim
we're bringing the broom no no no i-i'll
bet against and actually I was looking
at the disposition after Bishop h6 I I
think rook c6 was actually was display
the astrophysics was played be shocked
to see eight and in this position this
Knight has to be displaced the problem
is my king is very inactive for the
moment
putting the King on g1 is still not good
enough so you have to play g4 first then
after Knight to e3 I have a feeling
right now I'm going to throw in a check
you're going to move your king somewhere
g8 or h8 let's say here and now I'm just
simply going to take this Knight the
problem is your rook cannot move on f2
cannot come to grab this
viescha because your Bishop on c8 is
still under attack so you have to if you
want to play Bishop a 696 just comes on
the board and the position is perfectly
fine I will play King g3 this B pawn is
not going anywhere so I think white
would have been just perfectly fine he
has the activity black still has a pawn
up but it's not enough so I think this
is where Tim Randy lost the match guys
because you know Gary was very harsh
about the opening play of a Randy Singh
field and of course you know the way
Gary is he is having some fun but he
also takes this very seriously it may
have been as early as move to pardon me
I move for not move to but when this
move deep d2 d3 was played he had to
play d4 go into more occupying positions
and play it like that because things
went went south from here let's go up to
Maurice for the start of round 2
we've got game one in the books went to
team wrecks team Randy now has to make
the comeback Randy how do you feel about
that first game and what do you need to
do for the second one well I definitely
hurt our team out of the opening nerves
are getting to me a little bit it's also
about a hundred degrees in here so I
just need to calm down cool down that's
some cold water and make some smart
moves this time mm-hmm
all right there we go we're about to
start the game all right game two came
Rex white this time looks you bind setup
really what didn't work that efore ePHI
classical King pawn this is what the
grandmasters have been playing why is
nothing
[Laughter]
what are we in for last member
indianajill adore and I thought it was
actually an excellent choice
this of course I don't like nearly as
much Randy is out of the opening that
Rex is not capturing that part of his
prior sneaky attack on that point on f7
with Bishop c4 oh my gosh this looks
like some game of Paul more fees it
looks like we're close to some kind of
agent yeah would have been interesting I
think we should be 500 more you've got a
busted position right
this done Gary would like to take back
okay he's painting the position he's
painting cigs you know controlling the
central squares potentially night to be
sailing next one we are with he Cara
Nakamura needless to say this last line
was a little unconventional by Randy
what are your thoughts about this
opening right now Randy's opening I
wasn't that conventional but it was
awesome to see the look on Gary's face I
don't think he's ever looked at this
opening before so it's great to see all
right I'm sure he's never seen it before
we'll see what happens as Gary tries to
make the most out of this position and
vision
I'm very excited he's refreshed he
shaved his beard he's getting ready for
marriage he's definitely you know
winning moon and Gary is just giving all
the other players it's very difficult to
play under such a tremendous pressure
everybody watching save this very
unpleasant [ __ ] position can we
attack it before but not each - oh sorry
- five days so night h5 is actually a
pretty good move I think
Knight h5 to be all the trade on the
form don't hear enough of the
trash-talking what's going on upstairs
guys
[Music]
for from the bottom hitting the bishop
right this is happy to trade off these
dark square bishop keeping the bishop
the bishop is coming to these I think he
takes very interested Rex Sinquefield
looking at how big our masters are
taking over the position
Livan thinking do I put my bishop on
before or that looks pretty good I'd
like to put that Bishop on this roof so
that we cannot do a short castle exactly
but then you can wrong castle that's the
Pajaro nakamura coming in looking at his
position licking his chops
oh I just got access to the engine guys
it's completely
[Laughter]
[Music]
a lot of spectators you need and and
Nakamura trying to blow the position
open with the king and the Queen the
king and the queen line dr. King in the
center it's going to be five looks like
a shot when denied lose Bishop g5 where
do you put your knife yeah exactly
David Nabarro night h5 I guess really
and more recently I met we're with
Laemmle who played in the event had a
good result saw the result in st. Louis
wrapping him bliss this opening is not
looking too great for you guys yeah
difficult position but I think my stay
has some chances so we'll see
are you trying to keep spirits up we
know you're gonna have to go in next
know for sure we're not lost here we can
we can still hold on for why I think all
right we'll see whether they can survive
this position
Viking words doesn't look like it to me
and what his David played he's played
Knight to d5 posting up in the center
but can they survive until the amateurs
come in that's the question you could
become as some mistake well what if I
just stay calm define Knight takes d5
cy4 wasn't
six Queen to h6 and now I'm going to put
something on f6 after I trade off that
the 95 and it's checkmate and as you
mentioned the threat being Bishop takes
d5 in might actually that look before
many 95-96 how inside five looks like
you have Queen C 5 and queen of faith
Bishop takes d5 C takes d5 if you go
Knight f6 yeah rachel is not a happy
camper totally disgusted what are these
grandmasters doing messing up her whole
day with the pond and then play Bishop
III so slower approach and is taking the
to defy the main f6 Bishop g5 and Bishop
f6 it's always a very tricky tricky move
65 Bishop f6 correct correct yeah we
seen this simple means there's no easy
fun yeah yeah there's a pretty packed
so what nakamura sees that mislead well
that's
well right now fixify route 35 and you
cannot depend on yourself
yeah 67 is coming actually Queen of fate
or just back our queen the trash talking
going on until a third party for years
create forever right well that's a
winner but I'm wondering is LaVon got
something to say about it
he's winning in class so far it's over
well you got a try yeah I don't know
what's right here Kevin
these grandmasters are in very unusual
situation and that used to be had been
in such bad positions and not resigning
exactly they know that they need to
fight on because of the avatar factor
right so if you go Queen d8 and I'm just
laying three exchange the Queen's there
hope tasty so exactly yeah there's I
think combination five in d6 was in the
state of commute I think his intent
McLean to play these six and be sent
when you just got a link to exciting
this is a very much at the expense of
his mutinies colleague Queen d8 has to
be played otherwise you just get
checkmated Knight f6 check is below
[Laughter]
[Music]
ding Yan was actually afraid of just
like that shake it off shake it off
because we've seen him playing all two
moves before he's got a lot better -
really really bad
by Randy and his team could not recover
from them yes indeed I think the
especially with black it's a lot worse
if you mess up the opening and just goes
to show you that when you're playing
black you really got to develop as
quickly as possible yes well I mean
there weren't any very special moments
on that game to put point out only that
this move b6 was a really bad move as it
hangs the pawn on e5 and Rex did not
capture he just but I develops his
pieces but we have Maurice with
dominions
we're with Lanier Dominguez from Cuba
Lanier these kind of positions you
normally don't get in the grandmaster
game how do you feel to be offered this
beautiful position right from jump yeah
it's been very nice I think they
definitely need some opening work to
make it more to make it more interesting
so let's hope that they can still give a
fight all right - I know it's gonna be a
tough comeback well we'll see what team
Randy can do in the next game
we have it two-zip and team Randy needs
to sit down with Randy and say look just
play the fortress opening night f3 g3
Bishop g2 castles and get a position
because in this opening that they had it
was just over I'm gonna say as early as
move six look like a Paul Morphy game
act especially after the combination of
Bishop g4 and d6 that was all downhill
for Team Randy you're right it has to be
a fortress like position yes because
then you're gonna revolve through the
amateurs again and I think the one
weakness I've noticed in Rex's camp the
amateurs take a lot more time John Rex
there's things much longer than rates on
Randy so strategy has to be slow game
and I think Randy can get a point or two
here and make them obstacles yeah here
we got Roundtree Abbey - I'm your coach
Randy we'll find out soon start these
two games - stayin true to me so far so
good
accelerator dragon look at him go Rex is
confident solid plays short Castle and
it's all about momentum notice that Rex
I was twenty seconds north and he's
being very confident just castle come on
guy okay
finally have a decent position it's a
game 3 for Vichy that developers mad or
something in this game oh yeah we've
seen a similar structure in game 1 if I
remember no except on the c4 it's now
the ponies only five so it's reversed
yeah I prefer this for black because we
get to play for f5 whereas white has a
knight on f3 but we've got Maurice with
Randy Rennie sing field with us Randy
that last game you took it on the chin
yeah how does it feel to have someone
like Garry Kasparov criticizing your
opening moves uh yeah my I would call my
moves
abstract no I can feel the pressure and
I've got a little nerves I gotta say I'm
look around and probably the lowest
rated player in the room so I just need
to calm down and make solid moves I
think we're in a much better position
now I can definitely tell that my team
is a lot happier with my Gary was very
so I'm feeling better good alright
the game continues I'm sure Randy forgot
about some no actually I gave Logan one
lesson and he's not bad he's around I
would say 1400 I don't know what what
Randy's rating is he's already played
some amazing games here at ultimate
moves he just hasn't found his form in
this one it's very nerve-wracking to
play with these elite players no doubt
and Rex play well today but he sometimes
slipped and other ultimate moves just
the stakes were so high yeah he was also
very busy he was mentioning it the other
night that he was very busy this year he
didn't have a lot of time to Train chess
and he feels it I also feel it whenever
I don't train I feel the pressure I
doubt my moves a little bit more so I
think that's another problem we have
another rotation is David Nabarro I'm
coming in on the white side against
linear Dominguez he's just fishy's is
banded on the queenside
with this idea of a 3 C 3 B 4 and
both of whites bishops being shadowed
now it's time to prepare the expansion
in the Senate of d3 d4 f5 has to come
for black right very quickly otherwise
d3 before and it will be invite a big
job Johnny's getting ready I was trying
to understand the position before he
gets in well late where's Rachel I want
to see Rachel doing the same thing I
think that she's probably right behind
David doing the same thing trying to
acquaint herself with the plans in the
position before she sits in the chair in
the hot seat the hot seat indeed and
we've got Maurice with Yann with car
yakun we're with world blitz champion
Sergey car yakin who had a fantastic
result
in the st. Louis rapid and blitz won
seven games in a row as a matter of fact
what do you think about this start you
guys have had so far and we won first
two games and now the only problem is
that this position is similar to my game
against Carlos wasn't great for me but
but I thought but the hope our team will
do better you have any pointers for your
players your amateurs in this particular
setup any suggestions for the for the
amateurs it looks like Rex looks very
strong right now well I think I think
that Rex is our but with player and and
and in the curve game he played he may
have he played fantastically so so so I
believe in him all right Rex getting the
seal of approval from the world blitz
champion Thank You Maurice I thought I
gonna say as advice for the amateur
Sergei was gonna say don't study my
games but he was very accurate in his
assessment because if you remember in
game 1 Rex was actually opening up the
position play the move 93 g5 entered
with the rukon f2 so he actually won the
game yes that's my guy
that's my student yeah but you know what
I'm a little worried about team backs
right now because I know that John likes
I think I know Rex likes to think and we
have a one minute deficiency on the
clock I think that this game is gonna be
a lot tighter than the other do well
especially after this move d5 very
interesting oh those are happening
that's a very play for us looks like a
very nice move because that night could
come to d4 and the wrong understanding
stopping the knife and moving because of
the pin Queen takes d4 regaining the
comelet's to be accurate mode as that's
Bishop takes default it takes me for I'd
chosen by me I'm late do not hang it up
very good very good
exactly the Queen on d1 actually played
fantastically in this event that was
just like brilliant play mark
but we also defend the e5 party that
will be through the new food there is
putting a lot of pressure on yes is that
a good thing or not I don't got a good
thing I think you should go richness
when he gives you those mean looks I
mean I would I would be very scared oh
and we got the all-american matchup now
going on between the Karo and fabbi and
what books have we had after the move
rook b3 we got rook e8 I believe and the
rooks wanna cross getting into the
center defending the pawn on e5 and we
have no reason we were the former silver
medalist of the world this champion Y
and upon Miyaichi yeah and you've got
two points in the books but this game
looks tough
yeah this is definitely more tough but
you know in the previous game of course
it's all you know all all I could do for
for the win I gave it its sacrifice
determined just I mean I I think I I'm
the man who made the point it seemed
like you just had to take a piece in
checkmate no it was in depth all
collisions all right we got some
mystifying comments from the
trash-talking after a two in our logs
well I think the issue here is time
Fabiana or knockers we're gonna be
taking their time and I'm not sure how
they feel about the decision considering
the parameters are coming in even just a
few moves and are gonna be really
intimidated and want to take their time
it was well on the other hand there's
some argument from the
you set them up in a position where
everything's defended and they're less
likely to blunder things under pressure
so we still got what 9 means make until
the end or something I have to admit I
like white in this position just because
of the space advantage on me 5 very
powerful stone corn and he is
solidifying with the roofs on the white
keep it after this move rook e8 because
Knight takes d4 Bishop takes f3 Knight
takes d4 and Queen c7 it's going to put
too much firepower against Apollo in 5
innings but then you're wrong but then
you will lose your d5 pawn right and
I'll just draw everything will come yeah
I don't think even Randy can afford the
luxury of drawing with the white pieces
here Jennifer who do we have next to our
the next players very important
switching up the order a little bit
Christian to make sure that the
grandmasters don't face always the same
guys to make it more interesting the bad
and rusev done yeah that's why we've had
a bit of a switch off but have you seen
Gary in this game so Gary must be next I
think arrey wants to crack the position
for the v e6 like Fabiano what does he
have in mind Krista what absolutely
nothing together because after after
rook takes c6 I think the position is
just perfectly fine for black I think
you're losing a pawn he's played takes
c6 now this is yeah I'm clearly in
looking mood to be sure it's this shorty
was unleashed his idea which was to play
b5 and now it's up to Gary Kasparov to
after Knight a5 a5 and Oh Gary is
blinking at the position
yeah just work tonight
[Music]
I don't hate this I hear four for Team
Randy because when the amateur sub me in
any kind of pressure could be very
dangerous yeah sir
so having that dark square per second
pressure could be extremely dangerous
and it was a 94 was Gary's choice but
he's allowing a fourth 94 but there's a
disco in the position of the rights for
Quincy freedom okay so night see for
working Queen and rook and has it been
played and we've got more reef with
David Navarro we're with the Czech
Grandmaster David navara David this
position is wild what do you think about
what chances I like White's position
because I played so many bad games is
that I'm happy to see a position which
looks like this where it has some
initiative for the pawn and it's it's a
promising position now do you thing
you're gonna win I hope so but I don't
know at least we have serious chances
already saying that he likes this pawn
sacrifice by Bobby after Queen c3 work
we did see the move King h7 get
discovered 96 wasn't work already drop
back to e to bishop d5 but now i can
pick up his pawn back by trading
everything on e7 and taking on d5 and
we're getting to the 30th move when
Rachel and John are about to sub in and
that's gonna be a huge serve there guys
yeah you've got Bishop takes do we have
Bishop takes d5 on the board oh yeah
putting the pressure on is backed up
with his night is but is night on the
side of the board out of play
I don't like that let's see John has to
be active Queenie through would be a
good move I think in Gary you've got a
very jubilant Gary Kasparov Gary you
lost the first couple of games what do
you think on fidence oh and unless the
Navara effect happens referring to the
game of course he lost to David navara
have you had any advice you pep up your
team look at the concentration she's
just one more movie
yeah cuz farmer feeling like Rachel is a
champion he's looking forward to today
Wow takes it home bro we got Rachel Lee
who play some dominant moves to finish
that off
Rachel how do you feel you simply won
the game for your team like we had like
rain chances and feel like excited
you're intimidated by the fact that
you've got a NFL lineman big guy across
from you but still won the game she's
speechless right now as the whole team
knows that Rachel took it home finally a
win for Randy's team the score is now 2
to 1
yeah baby that's what I'm talking there
we have it the first coming in round 3 I
think trash-talking you're gonna get
elevated after this I love this because
Rachel's gonna have a lot of high
pressure situations and use world youth
competitions never gonna get more high
pressure than Gary looking over your
shoulder ya know Christian what do you
think well John is just playing a
passive chest up until this moment and
he showed it with his last two moves the
one that just simply lost the game night
way 5 was the first one Knight to d6
much better we're going to I this pawn
on b5 we're going to ID square on e4 but
most importantly this knight on f5 is
going to be a tremendous defender so
Knight to d6 would have been much better
instead of that he played Knight Way 596
Queen to c7 instead of Queen to e - and
that was problems all over the board
let's go to Maurice because he has big
job
we are with Big John Herschel John that
was a tough position and the young lady
took it home
no she played strong and and I felt the
heat there Tom was taken down what you
got to do to keep up the pressure is it
getting to you at all and no you got to
follow behind these fantastic GM's no I
mean it's tough they're playing good
moves and you know sometimes they get us
in complicated positions and you know I
can't tell you know left from right all
right well the other game has begun game
for now underway again the score is two
to one
absolutely Thank You Maurice and this
time it looks like Randy Randy's opening
is vastly improved first I'm sure Gary
gave you some on some fours to do four
stints if you like this your relative
[Laughter]
yen and Liam jumping in team managers in
I thought their rosters with wait yeah
but how does white have five minutes and
forty seconds on the clock I'm up 10
moves five-second increment they played
like all the rules pretty instantly did
they pay for the yum yum they didn't yep
boy they just blitzing out these moves
spectacularly I do think the
grandmasters left for their Amador's
with way to go Colin last time exact
they've been they're learning from their
mistake but that's the nature of the
beast in this competition because the
the amateurs are left the last ones yet
so they were going to have to face the
pressure exactly an Ian did not play
Peter scribblers moves a 95 d7 we played
the conventional 47 so the players are
still deep in the bowels of opening
theory 94 on the board
rook e8
Liam's action familiar with this
epidemic because it's taking more time
than with for example babe in the
voyages let's not assume very solid
position for blackouts in China here's
from that background kids it's ink from
the players but they got we need to mic
them up in the ether especially I think
f4 is being calculated right now in the
position I tell you what I think Gary is
very very pleased that there's no
sweeping yes for victory will it is it
enough determine the tonight they left a
broom it stops and also I think John's
gonna be a little bit what like to play
with two minutes in your clock when
you're on you have to play faster yeah
it's it's like the equivalent of a super
grab after having like thirty seconds on
the clock see that's a very strange
giving giving the d3 giving the d3
squared
maybe survive
on the inside a fight yeah you can put
on quite but yes yes why not
you've seen the trade because the rule
comes to be one my Mingus this is
probably the best position I'd be honest
I played so far somehow he always seems
to come in settling in for what looks to
be the best magic best game of the match
that's right the closest one so far and
it's all gonna be about shifting it over
to Rachel and John in about 15 moves so
fast move guys
well the thing is if you make some very
small inaccuracies your position can
adjust deteriorate very very badly
strategically at least so I think that's
what they're trying to be very careful
with their options
I must say I thought 95 to d7 to c5 was
the most compelling just the flexible h3
from Dominguez also but why not f4
that's my question why not and the night
would have been driven to a bad square
on g6 f4 was much more to the punch
and the problem is black let's play g6
the Benny lab no square for the night I
have to go back to c6
he did play g6 he's not intimidated but
after f4 Knight to c6 his night was
gonna be a little bit offside
well the bishop is also going to find a
very nice spot on g7 right now that's on
the long diagonal agreed agreed
I'm starting to prefer all black a4 a5
it was a very good move highlighting the
mistaken Queen dat 7 is white is
eyeballing an opportunity for Bishop 8
or more and things have gotten tense in
the playing hall
I don't hear a lot of trash-talking at
all suddenly Gary's shaking his head I
mean it's the position is not that bad
but somehow there's something that he
didn't like well Queen d7 he that Knight
should it be and I should have be posted
on c5 not on the e5 square hitting the
pawn on e4 Batali and Rachael in the
background they're waiting for work
hungrily waiting for her chance ejected
into the parade I'm pretty sure she sees
the position on the monitor behind her
because she looks like she's looking
quite in pain so we have a trade and now
and for f4 has to come on the board the
rook takes very nice for them to sub out
this is a big big move this before as
black is gonna have to allow a
devastating pin 96 nice use Oliv on
Bishop a4 e instantly trash-talking
LaVon said thank you very much in Gary
Kasparov is like angry
oh I don't see how he's gonna break this
this poor this looks like oh this is a
horrendous film that Gary Kasparov finds
himself in I almost feel it's losing now
[Music]
riess with fabbi let's go up and we've
got Fabiana Caruana Bobby he looks like
you're the butt of the joke right now
Aronian having a good time at your
expense
yeah I'm not sure about a few of my
moves what does it feel like having
Garak as far a follow up on your moves
it's actually one of the pleasures of
playing so badly I can enjoy Gary Gary's
response to this defense to appreciate
them
you see Gary not too happy right now but
deep in concentration as this game
precedes Gary in pain wincing horribly
and White has a huge threat right now on
the board the move e5 because the knight
came to f3 and after he takes e5 Knight
takes e5 ultimate pressure on the knight
on c6 that's going to be game over and
if you don't take only five
unthreatening nice musics I'm opening up
your King this is just looking very very
tedious for a fullback devastating
devastating Thirty there's always a
chance carry but if you run your time
down there's no chip I think there is
another random
coming off that that's true he's got
five moves and the loss of materials
inevitable at this moment yeah I hear
you and the clock is ticking into three
minutes and 20 seconds
this is amazing what did Fabiana do you
really played like two three incredibly
bad news Queen d7 G six in 96 and he's
put garry kasparov
in a devastating situation I would say
the tipping point was the move Bishop to
a very passive allowing the rook trade
on ba and then at four we understand the
move Bishop d2 by the way working a
played by Levon I mean played by Gary
quickly well what the plan is trying to
do is just pressure him on the clock I
have a feeling solidify his position as
much as possible and just pressure him
on the clock
yeah Levon so that's why they lost last
last game so trying to stay ahead in
this game but he five seems to still be
coming in with Florence two Russians
there you see yon and Sergei
contemplating the chances talking about
what he has to do well actually Levon
just played Queen beeping yeah he did
play Queen to be one right defending the
pawn on e4 I think more importantly he
wants to play Queen be one Queen d3
Queen takes a six how are you going to
defend the pawn on e6 and that that's
why I didn't understand the make Bishop
d2 the simply nobles yeah you could have
play Queen correct away correct okay
but now okay Gary recognizing this babe
has been sealed long before this played
the new g5 allowing Knight e5 and
somebody who'll have to do the honors of
resignation I'm afraid
look at that pinky hit and as Carolina
said it best the bonus of playing such
bad news is I get to see Gary man or a
zombie six setting up for that very
all-powerful pork on the e5 square Cara
big smile please it before even sits
down in the chair and he's smiling big
fishy I haven't had such a great
position against you in a long time so
it's not anyone anything Eleanor's
followed in this game yeah no this is
all on fabbi
five four three and quickly giving up
the exchange but this is all she wrote
as Knight takes e4 is going to be met
like wing be a check a devastating
background check which there's no escape
can be eight queenie 896 exactly well
you do get the if you get to play on so
then we should e2 then we should take
only four first rule takes e4 first
mmm-hmm I think that's the most I think
he makes before is a pretty one looking
for the Queen b8 Bishop f8 well met by
Bishop h6 exactly and we split queen be
a don't we just reverse the move order
anyway oh I mean oh [ __ ] actually so
Bishop fa9 takes e4 Bishop h6 that we
both look like winners to me now that
Kimura probably going through his mind
which one gives least chances of
blundering she's ready he's ready
gave her a better position she'd take it
down guys back exactly that's it and he
has played Bishop h6 o just does he get
one more move that is to say does not to
get one more me you have to Queen e8 cuz
Knight takes c6 will be well you get the
bishop on h6 at the end but I also get
the pawn on a six and that point on the
a if I should make
Mario's subbing in Rachel and John and
this is worse than coal for Christmas
the position that Rachel's receiving Oh
oh my I look at her go she snapped out
that Bishop takes h6 mu boy
she's ready to do her best for her team
John needs to play fast you need to take
this he's done it
t2 she very very quickly
Rudi one very important I think he rope
the d1 is a crucial move John has to
realize that he's going to lose the c3
pawn but he's got to get back that pawn
on d5 and more importantly when you when
you take a look takes d5 Bishop takes a5
is no longer on the board exactly
[Music]
definitely how many moves we have don't
forget it's Randy and rats coming in
there versus real wrong Jesus trying to
keep the position kill what do you do
very very logical move King f8 by Randy
very logical in turn and Rexton bring
his King David e-force explore
that's very unrest not sure that that's
the bet Oh
Bishop people check I think he had to
play King in seven but okay wreaking he
has played it
he's war bring your king to the center
and it's very and he's done it and the
great I think Randy could have had his
king on
v6 and now we're gonna see the Grand
Master technique you guys the big Rachel
said that was so fantastic that was
actually left Randy was much more time
in the pocket he started and that was
important absolutely and now the I mean
it's the summer of the endings because
this again the whole the whole drawing
idea for black very very critical
drawing mechanism is you want to keep
your Bishop on the long diagonal control
the a1 h8 diagonal the players team
Randy's Bishop is on the long diagonal
at present an e6 was a very good route
very quickly David Navarro has dropped
back on the grandmasters are a little
bit uncertain that they're drawing
chances okay King g5 but so give give
back another move King e5 then you
quickly play h6 got a quickly play h6 oh
he took on have said okay I don't like
that I don't like allowing the King on
the seventh grand okay but actually he's
going to have to get back I think King
g5 now once again you don't have moves
you have to withdraw your king or play
the move h6 I have to play h6 uh very
strong and now each for a torian's over
oh it would be and be all the difference
in the world if the King were on g8 and
the Bishop were on a1 then white has
been real real real problems to win that
position
and we did see a resignation with so
many grandmasters Rachel did great to
give her team a fighting chance that it
wasn't enough no and we've got Maurice
with Rex Sinquefield we're right with
Rex Sinquefield as they have at least 20
to draw so far three two one school Rex
how you feeling
you know I just think you you mess with
the best you die like the rest
brutal words we did see Rachel II make a
bit of a comeback in the game but it
looks like you were able to seal the
deal i I got Forks and Rachel's amazing
she truly admit she's the ringer of this
whole group she's carrying that whole
team you know it looks like it's not
enough the Rachel sits down team Rex up
three two one what can team Randy do in
the next two games but we'll see you in
round five coming up soon thank you guys
and here's situation Randi managed to
tie it up three three not over yet and I
think that in the next game it's all
gonna be about play fast play fast like
that absolutely Christian I'm very
pleased with team Rex's performance I'm
not so pleased with how John is playing
so far he's just making very passive
moves I have to I mean I know he's a
light lineman but still he has to go for
the offensive and we'll see if he can
pull it through but all the other GM's
are helping him a little bit are giving
him comfortable positions he got a
winning position in the last game when
he was under pressure though he didn't
perform as well so I think Tim Randy has
to put John under pressure that's their
winning strategy I think they're all
playing great considering the pressure
of having Gary look over your shoulder
and here we go Game five this is Rex's
chance to clinch the match victory and
we're going towards another Sicilian and
again somebody has got to tell Randy
that his
against the accelerator dragon is not
good but they want a game with this
opening with g3 Bishop g2 before he
played them of c4 that they lost yeah
the c-4 in the d3 which was much more
pass at least this routine the
flexibility you're going for c3 d4
closed on a Sicilian appearing on the
board that's my stress trash-talking as
I was talking for they're very
competitive they're taking this very
serious I haven't heard a word from
Nakamura actually isn't he's supposed to
be a big brother and he is a great trash
talker he's really taking it easy on the
tube maybe not to rub it in he's weaning
off the wrong did you see a big trade
and let's go to Maurice Ashley with
Levon Aronian Levon it looks like
everybody's very serious right now you
guys are dominating you feel they feel a
bit depressed right now they should be
because we're better players they should
feel depressed you're enjoying this
absolutely so what advice do you have
for them to maybe make a comeback I
think they should try Domino's or you
know some other game
pretty brutal Levon Aronian telling it
like it is Rachel look we have a
sacrifice
well Wow two pieces were sacrifice what
I'm shocked by whoever was that made
that decision taking it maybe you're
trying to give them a chance I feel I
mean maybe you know but we can blackjack
rookie three it's a very serious
competition can you imagine being on
Gary's team and being like yeah we're
just gonna try and give him a chance to
come back no baggers
no Bishop b7 check should be played and
f3 on the board as garry kasparov
yeah yeah yeah
something
that's good at Maurice with Nakamura not
more a dynamic player naka you like to
sacrifice what do you feel about blacks
position right now we're doing great I
mean the two pieces are much better than
the Queen and we're gonna prove it I
mean the positions are so beautiful are
you guys just confident no matter what
you do you're gonna win yeah of course I
mean as LaVon said we're the best
players and I'm the best always win
about the nuts are you like very
surprising move fighting fight quickly
from Jung making it's it's a team
competition now optimism is necessary I
agree
Kris him it's very important to always
keep a positive spirit and never get
angry at your opponent no matter how bad
I mean your teammate absolutely and
that's why I feel Gary is just taking
their own approach right now with this
a4 move it I think they're hit intended
rook a3 which is played that maybe he's
overlooked C 5 c4
oh and there it is and that is a problem
suddenly for white despite his colossal
material advantage there are certain
issues the main one being Mississippi
Bishop on c1 well d3 has to be played
the problem is after d3 I'm going to
play Knight b3 it's lacking the bishop
on c1 and I think the only way to
continue is just to give the route after
that rook takes b3 sacrifice the
exchange he's played exactly yeah leave
one for sacrificing upon giving up upon
to get some room for the rooks so ii d
CD Bishop takes d4 would be one
innovation and let's not forget Black
has two extra almost two extra minutes
on the knock
and what about might be three in this
case I'll work III take some be free
Wow okay baby
Bishop's eight-six very well but should
be took there is f4 so what are the
players talking about even for the rook
I'll take on e5 will take my Brook and
then I'll get some attack I never get my
queen over nicely knowing exactly ok so
after Fischer made six or just play
takes on e5 private but big
opportunities here abound for Yan I'm
thinking you should just take on d4 I
think that's easier to play especially
with the avatars coming in I'm like I
like that why you'd eventually I think
when the Amber's do so then I think I
gotta like the Queen I think it takes
more finesse to play the pieces
Christian yeah over and under what's
your what's your bet on the outcome at
this game it's a difficult one how many
grandmasters do we have captures on d4
that was a c4 Bishop takes e4 and we
have this position on the board the
problem is with an exchange and now it's
a pawn in an exchange right you're going
to take my mark on d3 but I'm going to
open up my pieces are quite advanced at
last the shock comes to e3 then the rook
will swing on the seventh rank if you
don't trade one or the last or groups in
general as black I would like to keep as
many pieces
absolutely and remember team Landy needs
a victory to make that yeah around 16
interesting I think they're gonna do it
though because I think it's gonna be
very hard for the ammeter is once they
stopped in 96 I balling that d4 square
that would be great yeah the amateurs
will see that they need to put the
knight on that beautiful office I still
think the queen is so good when it's a
matter of her Savin our outside I would
be very impressed if an ammeter
successfully play with the pieces here
so let's say you look to d7 yes
94 that's right and now I'm just going
to take upon I'm going to grab the bait
on a seven uh-huh saying that you simply
don't have any good discoveries with
your knife and we play E for they're
good move
Eve for a very good move because 933 is
coming kg - I don't have neither 3k rook
d7 ah right through c7 always swings
whenever you play a knight move yeah but
I really don't see it but what maybe
four but then Queen d5 I'm going to
write or Bishop III Bishop III I want to
control that logic or I was gonna go 95
to f3 that in any case it's not enough
but the time to be equalized and I think
that blacks can be in big trouble this
game because now that they don't even
have a time edge the power of the
Queen's gonna serve yourself I believe
so and that'll be great though cuz I
mean the final mountain that's what we
want to see yeah let's see maybe maybe
John and rest will surprise us and
manage to hold or even turn this game
around but I like white 93 to move 94
now the big time move will Vichy
play greedily and capture the poem on a
7c a tan
I mean I'm just renting burrkc one but I
guess you can just play Bishop III which
you want to play anyway I was just
trying to get both of my works into the
game we have understand being absolutely
Jennifer the C file would be the other
battle for black if he could double his
rooks and get some action going there
but it's a all ambition now the highness
a seven is the right move you would love
to force while to get the bishop for the
night because then the e pawn becomes a
deep on you know very very well erected
upon it's not it and the arbiters oh
he's out a smile who is he facing he's
LaVon or
don't get too relaxed
yes
landed what's up with that Christian I
have no idea surprise the college
actually I do have an idea he's trying
to eliminate that visa potentially oh no
milk over and try for a fortress
when Tom simply has to player B 1 will
be that's all he has to just keep the
look on the beef I'll define the PCs
where it's got a kind of a portrait
going to new Christian Rachel reaching
for a rook she wants to go after that
beef locator go the mark up to that
level from garry kasparov big-time
approval is very important by the player
Rachel Lee you said before right
wait no more easily takes f7 oh look a
and she's eyeballing that tactic oh man
rook takes f7 with a district on the
rook on 8/8 she saw young realizing that
maybe that was the blunder and Gary very
good move didn't know we happier at the
pawn on d6 instead big chances for our
they're giving huge one more move for
John
okay seven with Roberto saving move yeah
don't a fight I did this is still tough
for Rex against the Queen he's got 25
seconds very top takes the route but
then he wouldn't have force moves and
that's a big offense oh nice one by
Randy keep attentions make it harder for
Rex to make quick moves but now I'm
going to swing my rooks on the e-file I
cannot yet I cannot 17 seconds left Iraq
Rex has got a place gotta make a move
he's got a plate and he went down with
is he thinking about a counter-attack
against White's King inside of like an
aggressive I'm starting to like black
and that is because the King safety is
just a better for black right now that
is always an element in chess King
safety but we can't get too frisky with
the Ruxin otherwise there's gonna be
queening me so I think and look at Rex
go you've got it aggressive chefs Rex
don't forget the bow there alright don't
forget about the clock it's 14 seconds
left and there's a recording eight
hanging by the way are they gonna come
back in this game
cuz he induced Rex Noble Edward the
checks
he's only been five is a terrible move
why it exposes his King if you go over
you know I've King defy Brooke d8 and
then Luke see this is our King three six
can be six what has happened King be six
only move he has to play King d5 was
plays gonna play it means back in seven
seconds
oh my god there is one more movement and
Michael was indeed I like that now this
is a winning position Queen c4 attacks
the rook on f1 and the real quickly move
to do you want another plank pull it
here bullet with the guitar easy but
Whoopi seven big time five seconds left
7 g7 allows work these six Czech winning
back the material oh quickly King g5 for
opening up the 84 and they're playing on
the increment I think that this is this
is going to be a draw yeah this is going
to be a draw
we're up d3 Rudy - wow oh my god
Nakamura did it again wait he's coming
yes what the floor has been played I
don't like between c2 hitting the pawn
on g6 trying to avoid the white all
white needs to do is trade off a rook
and that should be enough to win first
king safety and garry kasparov he's very
happy as he's got it no it's all with
that Jeep on coming to G right now Gary
Gary is putting the finishing touches an
imperfect game I think the amateur is
honestly are over performing they're
playing a lot of people considering with
their planners a bullet would stress and
would make one again through the bad
gives up the seats efficient water
fountain on fishies very confidently I'm
following that opportunity to go after
blacks King I would say I would say it's
still another world
there's still potential for a blockade
there's always a potential for a blunder
but I'm thinking this is over why
Christian because I see rook a3 and
Queen and rook coming to the h-file just
blasting blacks King well you also have
to be careful of your own king yes sir
maybe I just going to go fish up to a
one Bishop to a one staying I'm a long
diagonal make sense will he do it he has
us very nice but King g4 don't forget
the queen is ready to go Queen h2 room H
2 to H 6 I think that she wanted to play
rook e8 and Queen h2 and threatened mate
on the h8 square but first he was a
little 5 seconds for Ginga and only one
high no surprising decisions going on
here it's the clock is the key factor
David David recognizing the main threat
is about the like we
Maurice well the most exciting game so
far that's certainly the closest of all
Gary that one was wild but you guys held
on and one I mean it was real game this
is this when you look at the quality of
the movies and since we had amateurs you
know and drink three times the stage so
okay you can forget the first five moves
twice at the end of the game and the
game was not spoiled I think it was very
good very tense game and so that's
that's the the best I can expect from
such a show three to two you've got to
win this one determined yeah we have our
hopes and rituals so she's she's she's
amazing so it was this cheap he did a
great job in every game here mr. Winn
but then again without without her
missing this win Bhuvan have the same
excitement alright exciting it is the
only one game left game six can team
Randy pull it off or will wrecks pull
away and get the win there's our
standing senator 3.14 braixen two points
14 Randy and you seem small print there
it does say no tie rates in case of
throwing match we might have to wait
till next year
I'm telling you Randy pulls off the
three three you're gonna have to give
the MVP to Rachel
the last game was really good it's
really good very accurate maybe one or
two mistakes not blunders mistakes and
that's huge for a blitz match they
deserved it they deserve the win now the
layer seven in the competitive mode
everything's on the line
Philidor but he did not play with this
[ __ ] about three giving up the two
bishops oh no I think Randy's gonna
botch up the opening really badly here
this takes on e5 is just a killer but
the Rex doesn't know Rex did
Bishop e7 yeah he's gonna have to give
up the two bishops now with 97 he
wouldn't what this is laughing because
you can't understand why somebody would
yell like a nap I think Bishop d7 was a
really bad move between b3 if the night
wasn't d7 the prominent he might will be
protected really annoying move it's a
double attachment and there goes upon we
got all grandmasters coming five five
five in a row we have 20 yes 23 moves
it's stopping east wind around
we know how is your queen in place we
have no wrong idea
but I sold my soul so your devilish plan
yeah
yes I will take what
[Music]
[Music]
that might yield some problems I need to
switch batteries real quick you just
have a pause there in our action as our
cameraman needs to switch batteries what
do you think's going on Jennifer can
team Randy put up resistance here or is
the pawn too much because I in the end
they're gonna go they're gonna go to
John and Rachel and John I it's not that
he's playing badly in my opinion I think
he's just playing too slow they don't
give him enough time he could just flag
yeah that was a national actor of course
in Game four I think what he did find
some good moves in the last game if I
remember correctly he paid that more
both ways that was big grabbing control
over the seventh ranked very important
and I think absolutely
Rex made that inaccurately f5 weakening
the seventh rank that was critical was
trying to attack hoping I've seen Randy
would take MC for Wonder and Gary has to
step in in the position where his two
palms down but he yeah he's got the
initiative which Gary's gonna say okay I
got some comp Queen takes a seven-night
d5 is not clear and who love lawns move
e5 you may have opened the door the team
Randy so Nakamura the only one wearing
orange you didn't get the memo
party time yeah these these shirts that
all the grandmasters are wearing are
available at the st. Louis Q boutique
thank Gary this is a five-minute game
Gary Kasparov and we've got more
recently favi I'm sorry
we're beyond Caruana Fabi you guys have
to give up one in the opening and now it
looks like it might be to what do you
feel about your chances I'm pretty
pretty satisfied with our position uh
I've never seen Gary happier actually
this looks like him in it and
I think that he car was also starting to
sweat a bit but I I mean Queens like
says seven has to be punished it you
really just can't make moves like that
alright the pressures on the gauntlet
has been thrown down if finally White
has gotten memo get your King out of the
center ninety five castles quickly by
white carry fiddling both players
fiddling the pieces notice is forget in
case cycle of it in case of a draw team
Rex wins
that's that oh you cannot be content
with a threefold repetition root ka
droopy eight or something like that you
have to go for the win this is an
Armageddon games absolutely that's right
so night at four with the idea trying to
play were k-8 and recreate and
questioning the Queen isn't gonna be
sufficient but Knight F where to start
absolutely because there's a pin there
could be considered metaphor and
watching the bishop on e to gary's and
looking should he take on e5 first
before potentially playing 94 too much
time good about the clock yeah yeah what
is the time one minute difference
other ultimate moves I've been the
quality of the Amador's play when they
have like one minute left on the clock
has been astonishingly good but don't
tempt fate wait Knight d7 b6 the night
on d7 wasn't doing anything how are we
getting back in Jerry Mungo came to trap
the Queen that looks like okay Bishop c8
but you're right a repetition is not
good enough
everybody looking Queen Queen 3 6
do I have a move such as c4 meanie
trying to cut the Queen out I'm thinking
that Gary just wants to play Knight f4
to d5 and just highlight for during the
nights bring the Knights of the attack
exactly but not that's looking on the
clock as well right this is gonna be
close guys so how many ponies does white
have dunes to count two extra parts oh
yeah uh 13 he has captured on d6 forcing
Bishop takes d6 and we see the
difference in diamonds in over one
minute
I'm not sure where I think I'm gonna
take your Bishop on d6 the desirable
Bishop c5 is 94 Christian and I agree
no white pieces cover his King to pawn
deficit you've got to get in that attack
gary is going wait whoa he's not being
practical here yes
it's team it's gotta think about the guy
following up behind him watch it
95 it's a critical moment though and if
you don't get the initiative required to
keep the game going then you're just
simply going to be 2 points down okay
rook e8 I just don't see any yeah Gary
needs to get all the pieces into the
attack and moving the bishop constantly
and most importantly does very well
without move 90 or you also took away
the f4 square from the knight the bishop
on c1 is now controlling that exactly a
huge huge move now coming in master of
defense to pawn advantage but will he
maintain that time advantage but he has
so many moves until the editors can
handle there's only 50 seconds left on
the clock they're still 15 moves so
Rachel and John enter the fray exactly
they that place of Oh Oh big time well
they're gonna give Liam there's 20
seconds I know that would not be good
he's the claim the bishop the Queen
needs to feel a little bit uncomfortable
I was expecting your move between a six
Christian why I mean you mentioned
before being able to whip through all
your clean back along the diagonal that
was not sir gays choice however his his
uh he's just trying to uh put those
pawns in motion
and grab important squares from
important dark squares from black also
maybe just break you should be to Lucy
one at some point
19 seconds left for the Indian world
champion 5 seconds do we see create very
unexpected I thought that was the file
that the rook wanted there's a trick in
the position 84 allows / k8 main things
to eat for yeah so I'm thinking that
this knight on e4 is either gonna drop
back to g3 or nothing else crucial
moment and serene how I'm gonna be going
under a minute well nice are you kind of
expecting oh but there's a queen trap in
the position rook a a queen 3/8 was a
smart green very sponsorship c8 and that
Queen really crafty move square then
whites Queen gets caught
beautiful move an actually after a
things before her okay a is also an
option Bishop to d3 working a and has
Vichy that was Bishop c8 in mind
Bishop see it has to be played and now
what's the point of it oh I think you're
going to Bishop c8 I'm going to take on
me take some before and then take him
before I'm attacking your opponent and
yeah night on a he's done it blacks
Queen and black his trap whites Queen
and this she bringing his team back into
the fray well I think that is just
slightly better right now absolutely no
for black oh my god oh one second one
second
yeah I think that night if it's an
either I should be able to gain some
special seconds first team up in nine
seconds they were down several times to
one second on the clock let's put it
this way guys this is almost impossible
for black
wait oh we should I being cool in here
we should they realize that he has a
winning combination in position
Queen versus two looks as we approach 30
there they go there they go
he's very fast yeah but you're gonna
threaten to checkmate I like that I
never really make sure there's no
checkmate you've been mentioning that
John has been playing very passively
massive chest massive chassis a sir
that's what I don't like about John
Smith yeah but here you can't really
blame them guys this is really really
tiny no no don't play rugby one don't
play what do you want but make a move no
go back okay that's good night see three
right now that's problematic you have to
play grabbing the pink soon John King
safety and they're done
combination party time up to the show
with Maryse Wow well we've got a very
happy and relieved Randi Ziegfeld Randy
didn't start out great but you guys
ended up tying up the match yeah I just
use luck when you don't have skill you
got to rely on luck just go with luck
that's uh that was tense that was tense
look like you're lucky fortune was one
Rachel II she you handle her business
whenever she sat down she's been amazing
it's unbelievable she's our ringer the
MVP young Rachel Lee I don't know what
we would have done without her let's get
Rachel on camera Rachel you definitely
showed some tenacity in that game how
does it feel to really help your team
win we feel like kind of the beginning
and then we started to play good and
then and then we won first the last
round is so important well
congratulations on a victory you were
definitely the MVP Congrats
there it is guys a 3-3 the no rubber
match great matching the good comeback
for the Randy squad and we've got to do
this again next year well thank you one
of my greatest ultimate move
position where Rex Rex flag fell that's
right I mean you know the flag was so
low for the amateurs it got down for the
seconds for grandmasters and the auditor
absolutely Wow what it's really finish
indeed well we want to thank you all for
joining us here for Ultimo's and
christian your final thoughts on this
epic ultimate move match well this was
my first ultimate move is a match but it
was so exciting and in the last round
navara and I think the quantonium were
making moves on their last second that
was incredible to watch and I actually
thought the team wrecked so I had it but
I'm going I'm going to have to have a
talk with with John because he
underperformed in in this one and I will
have to give him some more puzzles I
think everybody over performed in fact I
think everybody over performed I mean it
was a good match oh yeah absolutely
very exciting there's there's a lot of
tension going on a tie-break we're
thinking finding out whether there might
indeed be a tie rake will wow that
negotiations are underway and we should
mind everyone that there is going to be
a closing ceremony that will be live
streamed on our channel and you can
watch that on the st. Louis Chess Club
channel it's gonna be live here in st.
Louis we're gonna be celebrating the
winner of the st. Louis wrapping in
blitz Levon Aronian absolutely will that
be at six thirty years yes that's it
6:30 local time here in st. Louis so
that'll be 7:30 Eastern Time
Wow very deserving closing ceremony to
be awarding Levon Aronian his trophy for
winning the inaugural was st. Louis read
the rule is yeah let's go up to Maurice
and see what all the milling and is
about doing and throwing alright the
players don't want to settle with just
even there's no love in this building
they decided they want to play an even
crazier version where you do one move at
a time one move at a time
each player they're just circulating
each move no five moves this time just
mayhem and madness and that's what they
decided so that's what we're gonna do to
break the time all right
time control yeah we gonna have an
Armageddon there's black get a couple
extra minutes on the clock and I doubt
it no draws so it all seems like an
unlikely scenario I mean if there is a
draw then maybe you go finally agree
that this tie can't be split but for now
we'll see if we can crown a winner with
this a innovative format at the moment
that's going to me one favor Christian
I'm going to have to stick with my team
team Rx I have to stick with my team
until the end I think I agree I actually
think the one move will benefit us a
little bit because I think with John
having oldy to play one move he'll just
be like okay make a move
especially if it's a recaptured anything
yeah a little bit slower I think heads
Costard I don't think he's playing
poorly wait there we go reckless
experience and wrecking fields of on
Aronian he Carla doc amore Sergei car
yak in yonder pool Miyake Dominguez and
a John Herschel and new high on Team
Randy we got Randy's and field the
founder of spectrum studios and Fabiano
Carolina Gary Kasparov hashanah and Dave
Navarro Avila and Rachel Lee MVP play
Rachel Lee let's put it make that very
clear so we've got an innovative
tiebreaker in front of his folks this is
played really good speaking of any MVPs
oh well finding that mediate is sweep
this is going to be madness okay they've
gotta have a drawing of lives but I
think they're just gonna be standing
right and I think yeah there we go
there's a rotating rotation and look how
quickly they're off the pole so they're
not sitting makes a lot of sense
okay Johnny so big is difficult for the
other operators to follow him a check a
check by a brandy surprise Rex not over
I like this format
I like this format maybe we should do a
ranvi to be three and they're playing
very fast they're they're adding a lot
of lime on their clock Queens don't
hurry John don't hurry there's plenty of
time that's one of the mistakes don't
make quick moves seven I was expecting
95 Rex gonna capture the pawn Gary
look for the optimum move Gary just a
goodie
you notice that players are playing way
faster it seems like it's a standing
effect they know when there's yeah
nobody wants to be the one to burn a lot
o'clock big position here Nakamura the
first one to go into attack the fastest
man in the field but that's okay having
more than five minutes on the clock they
have to think it's a very complex
position they were playing too slow
before and now they're playing too fast
you know standing makes you go faster 96
just quietly moving
reading the night okay.come art is the
night going he was pressuring defy those
I would say Bishop Deeks this should be
too is the way to go not sure Gary looks
aghast like why shaking his head he
hated that movie 5 by Randy you really
robbed it was a big grimace the problem
is you're weakening the d5 horn and
you're also opening up that you felt
potentially for blacks troops slice and
dice slice and dice okay 94 I'm going
through exchange that night oh but no
yeah 94 looks very powerful 94 94 no you
don't want to take the rookin b2 because
without the dark square Bishop you're
wrong rejoice game Rachel's in the house
what to do no she's looking at the fact
that her rook is hanging she can pull
her up to D to the defender pawns that
would be the move the grandmasters would
approve it would be a very good safe
move why not throw can you I'm not the
praising you're taking my room but
that's okay they've got everybody nobody
nobody's thinking a lot this game I
think it's okay to take her time and
she's would lay the grandmasters move in
a nice develop a really nice you know
it's a Randy on walls rice
normally you want to play a to a for the
neutral look on brandy Gary judging in
the background yeah he's giving him some
scary he's behind on the other side who
you want doesn't work because of Bishop
they said maybe there's an 86 trick in
the position there is a Bishop after all
lurking on c4 that's the King on Jimmy
Oh Rex is given up the two bishops with
this move rookie five I don't know what
you've been teaching them think that's
why a Bobby
but if you play for I'm going to
transform i-94 Gary going on to the can
I know you like your pawns yes sir I
mean I know you enjoy your having an
extra pawn but still there's still a lot
of time left in this game compared to
the ones where they were sitting
five it's almost the original time for
black and actually after a four I'm
going to play a rocky eight and I'm
going to forever take the control over
the e-file which i think is very
important
well I'm saying I'm suggesting a force
behind me see - okay I don't quite
fathom that one well okay 88 and maybe
or about before try to take the part
team Randy thinking about however they
can do with this extra pawn in the
position I mean how are they gonna make
progress how they're gonna make progress
yes sorry how are you gonna do how about
you gotta do progress
whew in this tiebreaker things have
really quieted down this is not art and
science this is about the become
petition and winning 8283 did I see the
a for a for what I can always count on
fishy to come through with some great
yes it does Christian is recommending
the be forced where he's played Bishop
d4 I would get rid of that Bishop right
away with Bishop b2 maybe rook takes e4
was a big time move there
I really think what before was a big
time yeah and I think young knows y'all
knows that so he's trying to say how
should i prevent that move oh boy that
would have been fun I don't like this
bishop before I don't understand the
purpose of no that was not David David I
think that was Navarro no I'm wrong I'm
wrong the other guy's car yeah it may be
yeah hurry up Ken that's right with an
oddly moved and after this trade now
don't say say for know the b2 Queen is
directed right correct Rachel getting
ready to make her move
she's eyeballing the f6 world I bet you
she's thinking give me a lot the times
are equalized three minutes for both
players three five I would say rookie
five f4 f4 yeah it's it's a tough
position Queen f6 is definitely like the
young lady is eyeballing beam so far
good stuff she's played this is the
money move for her at four she likes to
attack she said I want to attack I want
to open the game out that's what she
said in her pregame interview with
Maurice if she plays at for Gary
Kasparov gonna give her a scholarship to
it's part of chess University said hello
oh she's playing with the big boys
he's dead of her and now it's a John
Herschel on move
I think rookie four is the best where I
think so - yes sir
and he needs to play aggressive
aggressive chest
he's been playing passive recive chest
come on John there are your when it
matters coming up with the big move was
John well you know what it's like to be
under pressure yeah I like it
now it's time Randy advanced upon f5
let's go open up the air how would you
assess this position yes sir
I prefer white because of the extra pawn
yeah well the bishop is kind of ugly but
it could be a beautiful flower if you
ever take that pawn on d5 I think f5 was
was a good move to try to always like
the rookie to and racks and missing
fields have passed the torch to the GM's
okay rook takes rook takes a that's an
easy move yes we wanted to see the milk
f5 and the doubling of the rooks on the
F file did garry kasparov
[Music]
but it's time Gary he's going into the
minutes under two minutes no I was way
you can't differential plays pretty fast
and so does Randy but it's it's the
other team that needs to get video for
f5 needed to play this important move
it's a big move it's a big move now
night things d5 has to be calculated oh
I will be very happy to see the loss of
that pawn I very satisfied by the way
that no you can't do it I was thinking
rookie 5fg HG Queenie fine
followed by d6 right but unfortunately
Knight d5 and in the firm but here
Nakamura is equalizing the time he's
rooting in the tank in this division
trying to figure out how to consolidate
and we markedly the fastest bullet when
you're on the planet is the one burning
clock
is she I'm balling his chance dangerous
situation now with the clock ticking
down we know that it's really tough for
the Amador buyers by the way if I'm
white and I'm thinking of what kind of a
five rook takes c4 is also an option
let's not forget about that thank you
the problem is you take on g6 and then
Queen to f6 or queen F to right or
window f2 and then the pawn on c4 I
don't work on c4 would have been left
hanging
take some d6 have a card very quickly
David now the times are almost exactly
equal with about a minute and a half for
each side there is that nice I can
increment but that's not a lot it's time
for Queen f2 guys hmm
all the pawns gone I'm kind of happy to
see that actually that's white yeah
because the bishop on c4 blossoms if I
quickly his plan is to uh King to g7 f5
and then play 19 to keeping pressure on
that any basics yes quickly five a-six
is very day it was a choice King to g7
has to be played and yeah work f3
stopping what a black has to follow up
with this move f5 I have a feeling so
what's wrong John is gonna look at three
to protect the e3 square and then rook
the three is on White's agenda and she's
go for it
come on Rachel he hasn't made a bad move
ahead in the ultimate moves she was G to
checkmate
oh that's the problem that's what she
and John play Knight III though because
he hasn't been done that's the big house
dude he has to that's all the
grandmasters quiet he's waiting for some
advice he's looking behind these a
Churchmouse
because they don't want to give it they
don't want to be unfair this is an
important moment absolutely but you know
you don't want to take too much time
he's gonna drip under a minute and
to the sink fields giving G to hitting
d1 he's going underneath a minute
you spent almost a minute on this move
he's calculating there it is before and
immediately Queen 66 by Randy Randy
Randy understood and not just gave you a
very very disapproving roofie there
white has won back his pawn and has a
great bishop in the position right
before me - seishin in the form of the
fact Peter Bishop was garbage exactly
now that bishop is a monster than item
b4 is really out of the game so we also
have a huge time deficiency here as well
look on tap for white rain and Rex wheel
19 seconds left for Rex things you know
and he's made a move okay big credit for
that move very very decent was wasn't
both no cuts one though yes we do have
work at 5:00 LaVon suddenly quiet that's
not a good sign yeah what is
trash-talker in this role seconds 10
seconds left our money back that's a
visceral display street from you yeah a
585 AC 86
I like puns for a reason it's a tricky
now Morris black can he do something
like night to see to bring his right
back doesn't look like it because
there's an admission fee to me all the
time somebody's day 25 24 23
knock has gotta build up some clock for
his community
it's Gary using the tank he's not even
looking at the clock it seems like what
they're trying to do right now is just
finish the game until Rachel and John
Compton oh my gosh
five seconds so now night since you
disappeared III that's no a five goat
late Queen c7 check you can't take the
bun on a five now it's Sergey Smoove
it's for second fact is he gonna make a
move in time look at that
Queen takes e5 two points to the good
suddenly trying to confuse Rachel but
John's not with both fields oh my gosh
unbelievable the trademark Sinquefield
move is struck again
Randy like father like son
what happened oh you taught me that one
when I was a kid we've been working on
it we've been working on it for years I
finally perfected it at the precise
moment so good about that wreck so you
want a game now you don't have to be the
only one who suffers and hatin in the
minute II if I said that right even the
money think of me whatever ugly stuff
anyway you know the year I did that a
year or two ago three grandmasters also
did it that year so they're following in
my footsteps
well congratulations t-rex did win this
year I think neither one of you probably
feel too satisfied with how this came
out um I'm happy my team mates are great
they're incredible I'm just blown away
with with Rachel's play and I think that
was you know our MVP
and so that was our biggest win is
having her on our team
alright the new discovery and Rachel II
will watch her future meantime team Rex
happy they got the victory one more next
year join us as has been a great event
now Rex infield lost because of the pond
erosion but you know what in this
particular case with so little time in
the pot something crazy was gonna happen
to end the game so it was gonna be that
or something else somebody was gonna
lose on time there was this was not
going to be a normal venomous no isn't
gonna be a hilarious finish and it was
served to us beautifully well Christian
your first time in ultimate moves you
can see why it's a party or that was so
exciting guys definitely a worthy finish
to the summer of chess here at the st.
Louis chess club and congratulations
team Rex
a win is a win no matter how you do it I
remember two years ago I think a pal of
Rex was mentioning three grandmasters
that the pallav did it against Nakamura
so Nakamura did gain two very important
victories with this illegal promotion
but very very exciting stuff and I'm
very happy to call all the action here
with you guys in the studio it was a lot
of fun the ball and you know I've done
four ultimate moves Christian and I got
to tell you that was the best chance of
any of them that we've seen like rook
hangs it was opening that opening
mistakes by Randy got his team and a lot
of trouble to start the match but they
seemed to overcome it and the games were
getting better still can't get enough
time analyzing the final game or maybe
yes I think they're analyzing the
position and looking what could have
happened and should have happened
because it was another interesting game
that's the thing real moves and I
thought John Herschel was gonna fly for
sure in that position he played a good
move there at the end
little interesting yeah phenomenal match
here as Christian said to end the summer
of chess it's been so real and it's not
quite over because we are going to be
having congratulation closing ceremony
for Levon Aronian who has won the
saintly was rapid and blitz stay tuned
to our channel it's going to be starting
in about just over an hour here at the
chest capital of the US
[Music]